So I was reading a fascinating asked
science on Reddit the other day.
Someone wanted to know what was
happening in their mind when five apples
were dropped on the floor and they were
asked to count them where they just
counting quickly or did they remember
what five things look like in response?
Reddit user surf,
Kate tindle gave a great concise
explanation of the difference between
counting and something called subitize.
Coming from the Latin subcutis meaning
sudden subitizing refers to our brain's
ability to suddenly recognize objects up
to about four,
which means that if you see,
for example,
one,
two,
three,
or four pizza johns,
you don't have to spend any time looking
at each individual pizza.
John,
you just know how many pizza johns
there,
but if you increase that number by even
a little more,
your mind loses the ability to grasp
what it's looking at right away.
Indeed,
the time it takes to make a judgment on
number's larger than four increases by
about 250 to 350 milliseconds with each
consecutive number.
That's because when you move out of the
subitizing range,
you actually have to look at each
individual item and count them up.
The way we do this is by taking the list
of numbers,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
and so on,
and assigning them to the pizza johns in
ascending order.
When we reached the end of our set,
whatever number we stopped on is the
number of items there are digging a
little deeper.
This process of counting as we know it
involves five criteria that was a little
bit corny.
First,
the one to one principal,
meaning that each object can only have
one tag or number name,
second or Dunalley meeting,
that the tags must be applied in the
same order every time.
One,
two,
three,
four,
not three,
two,
one,
four,
five,
eight,
nine,
Omega Jackson pollock,
third,
the cardinal principle or cardinality,
which I mentioned before,
meaning that the last tag always
represents the absolute quantity of the
set forth the order irrelevance,
which means that it doesn't matter.
It's irrelevant which order,
the objects are counted.
The number will always be the same.
And finally fifth,
the abstraction principle,
or the ability to apply counting to a
number of varied objects,
not just the same one,
used multiple times,
counting in this way,
extrapolated allows us to deal with very
large numbers aided by something which
is not innate to our minds,
but is an artificial symbolic system
which we've memorized to the point where
it feels a we know of a few cultures,
in fact like the Amazonian Indigenous
Group Moon Rico,
who don't have words for number's larger
than five or the Brazilian peter hot.
People who only have names for one and
two above that they just say many when
tested both the moon to Roku and Pitta.
People were able to subitize small
numbers and approximate large numbers
with the same relative accuracy as
Westerners,
but they could not gauge the exact
amount of many items without the aid of
precise number names,
subitizing and counting our incredible
capabilities of the human brain,
which we take for granted every day to
appreciate just how fast your brain
works.
I'll leave you with this.
Get your pause buttons ready and pause
when you know how many items there are.
So
the final point I'll make on this is
that it seems after a number of studies
that human beings are not the only ones
able to make quantitative judgements
about objects.
Certain species of monkey,
horse and bird can subsidize
interestingly like us,
up to about four.
The best review that I found of
numerical competence in animals,
well worth a read was done in 2011 bite
Zana Resonant Cova and Boris Rye out.
Sorry for the name butchery,
which I'll leave a link for in the
description under worksite and follow me
on Tumblr.
Asked me anything on Tumbler and twitter
for short little thoughts,
comment below and I will respond.
I will respond to everyone.
Also post this on Reddit if you like
what I do and want me to keep doing it.
That has been a great way for people to
see these and just get the word about
the nerd writer out there.
So if you like the nerd writer,
post this on Reddit and I will see you
next Monday.
Yeah,
I think so.